اما على الارض في السودان فنشاهد هذه
الصور الحصريه حريق الان في احد المباني
بعد قصف
تخللته مضادات ارضيه بعد ان حلقت الطائرات
في سماء
العاصمه السودانيه هذه الصور من جنوب
الخرطوم الدخان الكثيف
يغلق يغلف
سماء الخرطوم ونشاهد هذه الصور المباشره
لحريق في احد المباني يبدو انه تعرض اما
لضربه جويه او قصف لكن هذه الصوره الان
كما نشاهدها لحريق في احد المباني في
العاصمه الخرطوم بعد سماع
صوت تحليق للطائرات
وانفجارات وتصدي لهذه الطائرات بالدفاعات
الجويه اذا تاتي هذه الاشتباكات في اليوم
الخامس عشر
على انطلاقها ودخولها الاسبوع الثالث وفي
ظل انباء عن خروقات كثيره سجلت في العاصمه
بمختلف مدنها ثلاث لكن ربما كان الحدث
الابرز هو التحليق
والقصف من قبل الطائرات والتصدي
لهذا القصف من قبل مضادات الارضيه وسماء
ذوي انفجارات
هذه صور مباشره وحصريه لقناه العربيه تظهر
الحريق الذي شب نتيجه
استمرار الاشتباكات التي خرقت هدنه خامسه
لمتابعه المزيد
نجوى القصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات